hi willkommen zu blogm Tag Nummer 5 ich
befinde mich gerade in Mailand und wie
wir hierher gekommen sind das erzähle
ich euch
jetzt zuerst mussten wir den Zug zum ber
nehmen wo läust du
hin doch dann lief es nicht so wie
geplant was ist hier gerade los könnte
es sein dass wir unseren Zug nicht
bekommen kommt paar Minuten
schon also man muss wirklich sagen wie
der Zug den wir eigentlich nehmen
wollten der kam jetzt nicht und jetzt
warten wir gerade auf den nächsten zum
Glück F das aber so früh los dass drei
Züge zu spät kommen könnten und wir
werden immer noch pünktlich
da und angekommen hatten wir schon das
nächste Problem wir stehen hier gerade
vor einem kleinen Problem wir haben
keine Buchungsnummer weil jemand anderes
für uns gebucht hat und wir haben die
Buchungsnummer nicht bekommen und nichts
zum einchecken und wir dachten einfach
dass man hier am Schalter eincheckt so
wie immer aber nein es ist alles
Selfservice also selbst Einchecken
selbst Koffer abgeben was ja kein
Problem wäre wenn wir die Buchungsnummer
hätten oder irgendein Dokument um zu
zeigen dass wir es dass wir auf diesem
Flug gehören beim normalen Checkin ist
es ja so dass man ja einfach nur seinen
Namen gibt ne oder sein Perso und dann
tippen Sie darum und dann ist man
eingecheckt das sind die Probleme der
influencer die können nicht mal mehr
selbständig
Einchecken unser Zug war schon ein
bisschen zu spät 20 Minuten und jetzt
können wir nicht mal das ist das hasse
ich
[Musik]
special
assist doch danach lief alles wie
geschmiert wir haben uns an den
Sicherheitsleuten vorbeigeschlichen
haben uns reingesneakt und jetzt checken
wir
mal foodt aus ist in beriner Flughafen
find ich sehr traurig
immer also Bo ich glaub ich w aber Fisch
und Chips gehen das kann man nicht viel
falsch machen oder irgendwie schon ne
geil ja komm wir tun mal so als ob wir
in London wären ja Beats und roots wä
halt was ist das ist halt healthy ne so
Bols lass mal da reingucken nach Fisch
und Chips fühlt man sich halt nicht so
geil Beats und roots schon auch nicht
schlecht das ist eigentlich schon besser
ne es ist also wir würden uns besser
danach fühlen wenn wir das
Essen es gibt Protein Bowl Avocado
chicken Bowl vegan Avocado chicken Bowl
uh ich glau ich nehme die vegan Avocado
chicken
Bowl geil das fühlt sich viel besser an
sowas zu essen als Fisch und Chips wir
sind an fettig und ungesund schwer auf
dem Magen
vorbeigeschreddert
gut vorne oder
[Musik]
hinten
tschüss ich habe einfach den kompletten
Flug
geschlafen
und schon habe ich das erste mal meinen
Fuß auf italienischen Boden gesetzt wir
sind hier nämlich wieder eingeladen von
japoda nämlich aus einem ganz bestimmten
Grund es gibt einen Pop-Up Store dazu
zeige ich euch aber morgen mehr und ja
jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal dieses
wunderschöne Hotelzimmer
[Musik]
an
Timo das ist so ein richtiges fün Sterne
Hotel Scheiße Alter was war das für eine
Action gerade mit der Kreditkarte ihr
hab das nicht mitbekommen und von hat
versucht ihre Kreditkarte hat nicht
funktioniert dann meinte ich so ja komm
dann hat die zweite dann meinte ich ich
probiere das jetzt
mal und hat auch nicht funktioniert und
dann war te und dann hat auch nicht
funktioniert und beim also beim zweiten
Mal mit hat dann funktioniert und ich
stand da wirklich meiner dicken
Winterjacke völlig ungeschminkt und halt
angezogen wie ich halt bin in diesem
fünf Sterne Hotel wo dann dieser conge
wirklich gewohnt ist irgendwelche
Superreichen zu Dings und wir stehen da
so wir wissen auch nicht warum wir hier
sind aber danke und dann erzählt uns
noch dass der dickste Pool ever haben
die haben den größten Pool in Milan den
größten sparereich Milan und wer hat
keine Badesachen mitgenommen wir
zwei barkammern Badeanzug kaufen hat er
mir gesagt da kostet der wahrscheinlich
einfach nur 500 € ja wahscheinlich ich
wette mit dir ach so und und dann und
dann hat er so weiter gereredet und ich
dachte jetzt sagt er dass hier z.B auch
eine Shopping Mall oder so irgendwo in
der Nähe ist nein hat gesagt wir können
auch dem koncierge Bescheid sagen der
koncierge kann uns auch ein badan zu
kaufen reiche Menschen leben anders ich
bin reich und ich scheiß auf alles
dieses Bett ich will das genauso bei uns
haben oh mein Gott das ist Dope das sind
fünf Sterne
Kissen oh mein Gott ja Italien weiß
einfach was gut aussieht ne dann gucken
wir uns mal weiter um kleine sitzloue
perfekt uh haben wir hier eine kleine
Küche Wasser ich hätte jetzt mehr
erwartet das ist unser Kleiderschrank ne
junge ja also ich habe hier einen lieben
Gruß bekommen von von misses very warm
welcome to Mandarine ovent Milan we wish
you enjoyable things ja
Areta sorry ich habe das Zimmer also
solche Fehler die passieren ja wirklich
nur in fünf Sterne Hotels ne ja dann
probieren wir doch mal gleich die
Schokolade die wir hier bekommen haben
ne oh mein Gott Timo das ist so
lecker extrem dunkel ne muss es
auchprieren oh du eine andere
MP orange meine war besser warte m
boring
oh da ist irgendein Gewürz drin so
rude hat wahrscheinlich so ein
pralinenchef der seit Jahrhunderten
macht irgendwie so 24 Stunden lang dran
gesessen mir so das Irin Gewürz
drin lass uns einmal das Badezimmer
angucken ja falls ihr Mitleid mit mir
jetzt habt ne die Koffer mussten wir
natürlich nicht selber hochtragen die
wurden uns hinterher getragen of course
das Badezimmer ist heftig was heftig das
Badezimmer ist
heftig
oh mein Gott und die Italiener haben es
verstanden die Italiener wissen es man
braucht priv Alter wie groß das ist
einfach nur die Toilette und die Dusche
auch riesig guck mal sogar mit einer
Regendusche ich glaub miland ist auch so
eine Stadt wo die nicht so viel Platz
haben und dass S hier so Zimmer und so
Hotels mit so viel Space ist halt
wahrscheinlich so richtig krass weiß du
weil das halt voll teuer ist hier der
Platz glaube ich er meint ja auch
irgendwie die haben gesagt die haben so
ein Poolbereich mit 12 m Länge Pool das
der größte Pool in meand ja homespl
mehr es gibt eine Sache die man bei so
einem Bett hier tun muss und ich denke
mal ich muss euch da nicht weiter viel
erklären ne wir gehen rein in drei 2
1 ja
amazing oh mein Gott dieses Bett das ist
so groß ich kann da meine Arme oh es ist
gar nicht so groß ich glaube es s 180er
Bett so groß ist unser Bett das sieht so
groß aus ja ich bin mega glücklich was
ist heute noch der Plan der Plan ist
heute noch essen gehen mit dem Team von
ypuda um 21:30 Uhr ich kann es nicht
glauben aber das ist in Italien wohl die
normale Essenszeit dann gehen die Leute
zu Abendessen und ja und bis dahin
werden wir uns jetzt mal ein bisschen
ausruhen oder ich meine das war jetzt
auch eine lange Reise hierhin und ihr
seht mich jetzt als nächstes wie ich
mich hübsch
mache okay willkommen zu meiner kleinen
get ready with me Session ich schminke
mich jetzt denn wir gehen gleich noch
Essen mit den Leuten von jpoda mit dem
ganzen Team und dass wir uns alle mal
wieder hallo sagen können wir haben uns
ja seit Korea nicht gesehen
wir sind zusammen mit on hergefahren zum
Hotel ich freue mich ganz besonders auf
Naomi und Nika die haben wir auch seit
ja einem Jahr nicht gesehen und ich
freue mich so darauf endlich mal
italienisches Essen in Italien zu essen
ich habe schon gehört dass wir morgen
vielleicht sogar zu einem Koreaner gehen
was ich auch mega gut finde und was für
diese Reise hier mit jepoda mega gut
passen
würde
jetzt mache ich ein bisschen Werbung für
bauschies Produkt was sie zusammen mit
japuda rausgebracht hat ich habe das vor
zwei Tagen das erste Mal benutzt schaut
euch dieses Ding an total toll das mache
ich mir hier ein bisschen auf die Wang
so drauf das hat so ein bisschen Rosas
Stich und hier ein bisschen und das gibt
so ein richtig schönen
Glow hat so ein
Highlight ich weiß gar nicht ich habe
das Gefühl in dem Licht sieht das gerade
noch mal viel geiler aus oh mein Gott me
oh das macht so die Haut das sieht so
richtig healthy oh das mache ich mir
auch noch aufs
Auge mit root am Auge mus ich aufpassen
in dem Vlog wo wir unseren tanbaum
geschmückt haben habe ich so roten
Lidschatten benutzt das sah einfach
nicht so gut aus muss ich jetzt im
Nachhinein sagen ich dachte noch ich
mach so ein bisschen auf cute aber WoW
und wenn und wir packen hier einfach
noch mal Werbung hin dann kann ich euch
das ganz no mal zeigen der get glossy
Stick von bausi und jepoda amazing also
der hat so ein leicht plumigen Effekt so
ein bisschen frisch ist der aber
wirklich so ganz angenehm ölig auch
toll und wo wir schon mal bei
koreanischer Beauty sind ich habe ja
dieses Jahr auch von yyle den
Adventskalender ausgepackt und das war
das einzige Video wo ich so Tonprobleme
hatte dass ich das Video einfach nicht
online stellen konnte und hier war
dieser glowy Stick drin und der ist so
perfekt wenn man sich einfach hier
in die corners und vielleicht auch so
hier ein bisschen unten Glitzer machen
möchte weil das total kontrolliert ist
und wenn ich schon mal von japoda
eingeladen wurde nach Mailand zu kommen
dann werde ich natürlich auch ein
bisschen Korean Make-up machen habe ich
lange nicht gemacht freue mich voll
drauf obwohl meine Augenbrauen sind
eigentlich schon wieder zu doll für
Korean Make-up Koreanerin die machen das
ja eher so also die gehen sich das eher
nur so nach
hinten ich freue mich so ich freue mich
so ich habe so
Bock aber ehrlich gesagt auch wenn
dieses Hotel mega schön ist ne man fühlt
sich schon selbst wenn man im
Eingangsbereich ist als ob man hier
nicht so wirklich hingehört ne also die
Menschen sind ja alle super nett aber
sie sind so zu nett vielleicht liegt
auch daran dass ich einfach aus Berlin
bin und ich nicht gewohnt bin dass Leute
irgendwie nett sein können ist einfach
so muss man sagen aber ja man fühlt sich
halt schon so ein bisschen wie ein
imposter man gehört hier eigentlich
nicht
hin und ich habe das Gefühl die riechen
das auch aber ansonsten wenn man das gut
ignorieren kann und und da gut drüber
stehen kann dann ist das halt mega cool
so eine experience und da bin ich schon
echt extrem dankbar und Tim und ich
freuen uns extrem auf die nächsten Tage
es gibt hier einfach einen Swarowski
Tannenbaum und ihr wisst wenn Swarowski
ruft folge ich diesem
Ruf zieh mich jetzt noch schnell
um und dann geht's ins
Restaurant und jetzt haben wir uns
schick gemacht und gehen die beste Pizza
der Welt Essen so wurde uns das
angekündigt mal schauen ob das
stimmt das war mein Outfit of the night
Slay Slay Slay Queen setz D noch mal hin
perfekt du passt in ein fünf Sterne
Hotel oh wer kommt denn da ist das die
bauschi oh mein Gott ich freue mich
gerade habe ich noch ihr lippenprodukt
aufgetragen und jetzt darf ich sie
selbst umarmen das ist der Timo der
freut sich das ist Käsesoße die auf
Pizza noch aufgetragen wird und das das
ist meine Pizza eine Pizza Margarita und
ich war mir nicht so sicher sollte ich
die Pizza schneiden und in kleinen
Stücken essen oder als ein ganzes Stück
ich habe sie jetzt einfach in die Hand
genommen und der erste bis war wirklich
eine experience und dieser cheesebow oh
mein Gott yummy yummy love in my
tummy so Leute wir sind wieder zu Hause
das Essen war mega lecker aber ich würde
nicht sagen das ist die beste Pizza die
ich jemals gegessen habe das also ich
finde dann deine tatsächlich sogar
besser yes es tut mir leid für Dennis
ich weiß du hast viele Preise bekommen
aber die Pizza war okay ich liebe ich
liebe den creepy kellerwebe und ich Gee
mich jetzt Abschminken es ist 22 Uhr wir
sind ziemlich müde wir haben morgen ganz
schön viel vor wir gehen zum Pop-Up
Store von jepoda ich bin sehr gespannt
was uns da erwartet es gibt wohl ein
Skin analyzing Zeug haben wir irgendwie
schon gehört
und ja ich hoffe euch hat die Folge
heute gefallen und die nächsten Tage
erkunden wir noch me
Mailand